[Musique]
c'est comme chaque soir avec Anthony
Saint-Léger bonsoir Anthony bonsoir à
tous sobriété énergétique Anthony le
terme et sur toutes les lèvres dans un
contexte de flambée des prix de
l'énergie en raison notamment de la
terre en Ukraine de quoi donner des
idées à ceux qui diffusent de fausses
informations effectivement de nombreux
gouvernements appellent leur citoyens à
réaliser des économies d'énergie en vue
notamment du prochain hiver et depuis 10
jours on peut voir sur les réseaux
sociaux cette affiche que l'on va
découvrir ensemble regarder elle
émanerait de la Confédération suisse et
elle nous délivre ce message en allemand
votre voisin chauffe sa maison son
habitation à plus de 19 degrés merci de
nous en informer et de donner ce numéro
d'évoquer ici également une récompense
de 200 francs suisses c'est un peu moins
de 200 euros une affiche que l'on va
retrouver sur Twitter Facebook
télégramme et c'est justement sur le
canal telegram qui a choisi le
propagandiste russe pour
Vladimir zoloviev pardon pour la
diffuser en évoquant un espionnage du
21e siècle avec vous le voyez une
publication qui accumulé plus de 300 50
000 vues affichent qui a été prise pour
argent comptant par de nombreux
internautes qui s'en sont insurgés ici
par exemple celui-ci de de dénoncer cet
appel à la délation ou cet autre de d'y
dénoncer lui aussi une nouvelle manière
de coopérer et d'évoquer même regarder
une pratique digne de la stasile la
politique la police la politique
d'Allemagne de l'Est entre 1950 et
1990 sauf qu'Anthony cette affiche non
seulement n'aimes pas des autorités
suisses mais elle n'existe tout
simplement pas effectivement on va la
regarder à nouveau ensemble même si il
faut préciser que ce logo que vous voyez
là celui de la Confédération suisse est
tout à fait officiel tout comme
d'ailleurs le numéro que vous voyez ici
c'est un vrai numéro de téléphone c'est
celui du service de presse du
Département fédéral de l'énergie Suisse
mais comme nous a confirmé à la
rédaction des Observateurs de France 24
la porte-parole de ce département
fédéral de l'énergie Suisse il s'agit
bien d'une manipulation et c'est
justement ce qu'on va vous montrer ce
soir un détail toutefois pouvait nous
mettre la puce à l'oreille et veiller
les soupçons c'est ce mot anonyme qui
pouvait effectivement paraître un petit
peu ce grenu donc la première étape va
consister en une recherche d'image
inversée et vous allez le voir on va la
faire via tin high pourquoi teen high
c'est un outil qui est assez
révélateur assez efficace lorsqu'il
s'agit d'une manipulation graphique de
photos détournées et vous le voyez les
résultats plusieurs banques d'image
comme celle-ci par exemple ça va nous
donner donc l'origine de la femme de
l'affiche mais vous l'aurez noté pas
celle du fond ça nous amène donc à la
deuxième étape on va là encore faire une
recherche d'image inversée mais cette
fois en prenant la même image mais en
masquant la fiche pour ne garder que le
fond l'arrière-plan on l'a fait cette
fois via Yandex le moteur de recherche
russe et regarder
bingo on tombe là encore sur une banque
d'image et vous voyez bien on va faire
le comparatif avec la photo virale que
l'on retrouve
le même panneau en arrière-plan et le
même reflet ici que l'on peut voir ici
et tout simplement parce que vous pouvez
mettre sur cette bande d'image la photo
que vous souhaitez une photo de vous une
photo de votre chien bref vous pouvez
faire tout ce que vous voulez et c'est
justement ce qu'on fait les internautes
vous l'aurez compris donc il ne s'agit
pas d'un appel à la délation de la part
du Conseil fédéral suisse notez
toutefois que plusieurs ordonnances sont
actuellement en projet de la part du de
la Confédération helvétique pour
justement restreindre l'énergie
l'utilisation de l'énergie que ce soit
sur les lieux de travail ou dans les
domiciles par exemple comme limiter la
température à 19 degrés mais ce serait
uniquement en cas de pénurie merci
beaucoup Anthony pour info intox rester
avec nous sur France 24 la suite de
Paris direct c'est dans quelques minutes
[Musique]